"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Amin Maalouf, dans
"Le naufrage des civilisations",
un de vos derniers livres,
paru chez Grasset,
vous dites contempler
le monde arabe avec angoisse.
Est-ce que cette angoisse,
c'est celle aussi
qui vous tient quand
vous contemplez l'Afrique ?
-Dans l'ensemble, oui.
Je dirais qu'il y a
des différences entre les pays.
Il y a des pays qui arrivent
à inventer une place
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui.
Mais dans l'ensemble,
c'est inquiétant. Pas seulement
pour le monde arabe
et pour l'Afrique,
mais pour le monde entier.
-"Le naufrage des civilisations",
peut-on dire que l'Afrique
est une civilisation ?
Il y a plusieurs
civilisations en Afrique.
-C'est toujours difficile
de parler d'une civilisation.
Y a-t-il une civilisation
occidentale ?
Oui et non. Il y a
une civilisation occidentale,
et en même temps,
il y a des nuances,
des différences
d'un pays à l'autre,
d'un continent à l'autre.
Mais je pense que ces termes
aident à approcher un peu
de la réalité,
à essayer de décoder
un peu la réalité.
L'Afrique est extrêmement
diverse. On a besoin,
quand on regarde
de l'extérieur,
de trouver des points communs,
de généraliser un peu.
On ne peut pas regarder dans
le détail chaque élément culturel.
C'est vrai qu'on peut parler
de la réalité africaine,
mais il faut savoir
que c'est une approximation.
-Bien sûr.
Vous êtes né au Liban,
Franco-Libanais,
mais vous avez passé
une grande partie
de votre jeunesse en Egypte.
Vous avez été directeur de
la rédaction de "Jeune Afrique",
le grand hebdomadaire
panafricain francophone.
Et vous êtes l'auteur d'un livre
admirable, "Léon l'Africain",
qui est en fait
la vie romancée
d'Hassan al-Wazzan
qui est dit "Léon l'Africain".
Il a écrit
"Description de l'Afrique"
qui est une description
très minutieuse
de ce continent africain.
Ce livre-là
a inspiré énormément
tous les explorateurs
du 19e et du 20e siècle.
Pourquoi l'Afrique
fascine et a fasciné autant ?
-Ce livre n'a pas uniquement fasciné
des gens comme vous et moi.
Il y a un personnage,
on ne le sait pas beaucoup,
qui a été fasciné
par la traduction anglaise
de ce livre, c'est Shakespeare.
-Ah !
-Des spécialistes de Shakespeare
considèrent
que le personnage d'Otello
lui a été inspiré
par le récit
de Léon l'Africain
qu'il avait lu
dans une traduction
qui est sortie au début
du 17e siècle, vers l'an 1600.
Et on sait qu'il l'avait lue
et qu'il avait noté
qu'il y avait une forme
de jalousie sur laquelle
insiste beaucoup Léon l'Africain
dans certains de ses récits.
Et il l'a attribué à Otello.
Donc, il y a
des influences remarquables
liées à ce livre.
-Et à Otello.
-Absolument.
-Votre parcours, c'est un parcours
de migration, de nomadisme.
L'Afrique, c'est le nomadisme
par définition, non ?
-Je me suis passionné
très tôt pour l'Afrique.
Peut-être à l'origine
parce que ma petite enfance
s'est passée
en partie en Egypte,
qui était le pays
de la famille de ma mère.
Mais c'est vrai que
mes premières passions,
quand j'ai commencé
à observer le monde,
étaient liées à l'Afrique.
Mes premières lectures
aussi étaient liées à l'Afrique.
Une de mes premières
indignations,
quand j'ai eu 17 ou 18 ans,
que je voulais changer le monde,
était liée à l'apartheid.
J'étais tellement indigné
que l'on puisse parler
de séparation des races.
C'était une chose qui
me paraissait insupportable.
-Révoltante.
-Et je dirais que c'était
ma première révolte d'adolescent.
Dès mes débuts
comme journaliste,
j'ai voulu aller en Afrique.
-Vous avez d'abord travaillé
pour un quotidien libanais.
-Oui, en 71.
Un de mes premiers
grands voyages
et une de mes premières passions,
c'était l'Afrique orientale.
L'Ethiopie, notamment.
Quand il y a eu le début
de la révolution éthiopienne,
je me suis pris de passion
pour ce pays
et j'ai commencé à y aller souvent.
-La fin d'Haïlé Sélassié.
-Oui, j'étais probablement
un des rares journalistes
étrangers à avoir assisté
sur place à la chute
d'Haïlé Sélassié.
Le 12 septembre 74, j'étais là
et je me souviens encore
d'amis éthiopiens
qui m'ont amené avec eux
parce qu'ils manifestaient
dans les rues.
J'ai manifesté avec eux pour
célébrer la fin de la monarchie.
Depuis, malheureusement,
les choses se sont mal passées.
En tout cas, à la fin
du régime monarchique...
-Il y a eu ce qu'on appelle
un "Négus rouge".
-Oui, il y a eu Mengistu,
des massacres...
-La guerre avec l'Erythrée.
-Mais c'était
des événements fascinants.
-Parce que l'Ethiopie,
c'est aussi un pays
de grande culture,
et de culture chrétienne,
les gens
ne le savent pas beaucoup.
-Je crois que tous ceux qui
se passionnent pour l'Afrique
ont un faible pour l'Ethiopie,
parce que ça a été
le pays qui a gardé
la dignité de l'Afrique
quand toute l'Afrique
a été occupée,
quand elle a été colonisée.
L'Ethiopie
est restée indépendante
jusqu'au moment où elle a été
attaquée par Mussolini,
mais elle s'est battue et
elle est restée comme un symbole.
Ce n'est pas par hasard que
Senghor parle "des éthiopiques".
Ce n'est pas par hasard
qu'il y a eu,
même dans les Antilles,
les rastafaris qui étaient
inspirés par ras Tafari
qui était le Négus.
-Les Jamaïcains.
-Absolument.
Donc, l'Ethiopie a toujours été
dans l'imaginaire
de ceux qui aiment l'Afrique.
Elle a toujours eu
une place à part.
-Le reggae est très écouté.
D'ailleurs, il y a un festival
de reggae en Ethiopie tous les ans
qui a beaucoup de succès.
Amin Maalouf, pourquoi en Afrique
de l'Ouest, par exemple,
il y a énormément
de Libanais qui tiennent
une grande partie du commerce ?
Quelle est l'explication de cela ?
-Les Libanais ont émigré partout.
Je définis parfois le Liban comme
une montagne au bord de la mer.
La montagne préserve l'identité
et le bord de mer
ouvre vers le reste du monde.
Les Libanais
vivaient sur une terre aride,
souvent sous des régimes
pas très accueillants,
pas très encourageants
pour l'épanouissement
de la personne.
Et ils ont toujours
eu tendance à partir.
Avant même le Liban,
la première grande migration
remonte à près de 3000 ans,
quand Didon a quitté Tyr
avec beaucoup de ses proches
pour aller fonder Carthage.
C'est une grande migration
de même type,
parce que la vie
devenait étroite,
en quelque sorte,
dans son propre pays.
Tout au long de l'histoire,
les Libanais sont partis.
C'est vrai
qu'ils sont partis en Afrique,
mais ils sont partis
en Amérique latine,
en Amérique du Nord,
en Australie, partout.
Ils se sont éparpillés dans le monde
entier, ou alors en France,
comme c'est mon cas maintenant.
-Il y a de la famille Maalouf,
votre famille,
en Afrique de l'Ouest,
au Sénégal, en Côte d'Ivoire ?
-Non. J'ai rencontré des Maalouf
en Algérie et en Tunisie,
des gens de ma famille
qui avaient émigré là.
C'est moins fréquent,
mais il y en a eu.
En revanche,
il y a beaucoup de gens
de ma famille au Brésil
et en Amérique du Nord.
Au Brésil,
il y a des villages entiers.
-Il y a des Libanais
en Afrique de l'Ouest
et en Afrique de l'Est,
là, ce sont des Indiens
qui sont arrivés notamment
pour la construction
du chemin de fer.
-Les Indiens sont arrivés
parce que c'était
l'Empire britannique.
Beaucoup de gens circulaient
à l'intérieur
de l'Empire britannique,
comme au sein
de l'Empire français.
Les Libanais
sous mandat français
venaient
dans d'autres territoires
comme le Sénégal
ou la Côte d'Ivoire.
Pour l'Angleterre, il y a eu une
très grande présence sur la côte
qui fait face à l'Asie.
Il y a plein
de personnages célèbres
qui sont nés
dans cette région du monde
avant de venir en Angleterre.
Je citerais Rishi Sunak
dont la famille vient de là.
-Le Premier ministre.
-Ou alors Freddie Mercury
qui est né à Zanzibar
dont la famille
vient également de là.
-Le chanteur de Queen.
-Il y a beaucoup de cas.
-Et on peut aussi citer,
d'une certaine façon,
Gandhi qui est né
en Afrique du Sud,
ce que les gens savent peu.
-Gandhi a fait une partie de
sa carrière en Afrique du Sud...
-Il était avocat.
...en se battant contre l'apartheid.
Son premier combat,
avant même celui
contre la colonisation en Inde,
c'était contre l'apartheid.
-Aujourd'hui,
un des grands fléaux
du 21e siècle,
c'est celui
de l'immigration contrainte
souvent obligée par la misère,
par le réchauffement climatique,
par les guerres.
Et beaucoup d'Africains migrent
vers ce qu'ils pensent être
l'eldorado. C'est une tragédie
du continent africain,
cette obligation
de quitter leur continent ?
-Nous sommes dans un monde
où il n'y a plus de frontières
aux images.
Chacun sait comment
les choses se passent ailleurs
et les gens ont envie d'aller
là où ils peuvent vivre mieux.
Je dirais qu'il y a
un paradoxe à notre époque,
c'est qu'il est beaucoup plus
difficile de voyager, d'émigrer.
Du temps de mes grands-parents,
on descendait,
on prenait le bateau,
on n'avait pas besoin
de passeport ni de visa,
on allait là où on voulait.
Ils se retrouvaient
à Buenos Aires ou à New York.
Aujourd'hui,
nous sommes dans un monde
qui est prétendument ouvert,
mais qui est
extrêmement réglementé,
extrêmement fermé.
Je comprends les gens
qui ont envie d'aller ailleurs.
Rien n'oblige quelqu'un à rester
à l'endroit où il est né
et à vivre une vie misérable.
Et en même temps,
on ne peut pas
ne pas comprendre aussi
ceux qui vivent dans un pays
et qui voient arriver
des gens de l'extérieur
et qui ont envie
de préserver leur mode de vie.
Malheureusement,
il n'y a pas de solution.
Nous sommes dans un monde...
-Vous êtes pessimiste
à ce point-là ?
-Il n'y a pas de solution.
On ne va pas développer
le monde entier au même niveau.
Il y aura toujours
des différences
de développement
d'une région à l'autre.
A moins de fermer
toutes les portes,
on tentera d'aller
là où on peut vivre mieux.
Ce n'est pas par hasard
que dans le monde entier
il y a une montée
des mouvements identitaires,
parfois xénophobes
qui ne veulent pas
voir arriver les autres.
Je m'en lamente, vous
vous en lamentez peut-être,
mais je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait de solution.
C'est une réalité
avec laquelle nous vivons.
Nos enfants et petits-enfants
vivront aussi avec cette réalité
d'un monde
qui est difficile à gérer.
-L'assimilation, l'intégration,
ce sont des notions
qui sont impossibles
à concrétiser ?
-Ce sont des notions
qui fonctionnent
avec le petit nombre,
qui fonctionnent beaucoup moins
avec la multitude.
Vous pouvez assimiler des gens
qui arrivent par petites doses,
surtout si vous partagez
un certain nombre
d'appartenances communes.
Quand on dépasse
un certain seuil,
ça devient
bien plus difficile.
-Le départ de beaucoup d'Africains
vers l'Europe,
c'est souvent le départ
de gens qui n'appartiennent pas
aux classes les plus pauvres,
les plus modestes.
C'est une des tragédies
de l'Afrique de voir ses élites,
celles qui ont les moyens,
partir.
C'est ça qui est terrible,
aussi, pour l'Afrique,
elle se vide de ses cadres.
-Vous avez entièrement raison,
mais c'est vrai
partout dans le monde.
Quand on voit arriver
des gens en haillons,
on a l'impression que
c'est la misère du monde.
-Les damnés de la Terre.
-Ceux qui partent
sont les gens qui ont encore
la capacité de partir,
qui ont un esprit d'initiative,
qui ont la volonté
de chercher une vie meilleure.
Et vous avez parfaitement
raison de le dire,
ceux qui partent
sont ceux qui,
théoriquement, pourraient
développer leur pays.
Mais on ne peut pas leur imposer
de développer leur pays.
Malheureusement,
j'en sais quelque chose,
il y a des moments
où on est obligé de partir,
car on ne peut pas résoudre
les problèmes de son pays,
on ne peut pas arrêter
une guerre civile,
on ne peut pas développer
un pays en une génération.
Et donc, on est obligé
de faire un choix pour
soi-même, pour sa famille.
Et ce choix est souvent
celui de partir.
-Aujourd'hui, l'Afrique compte
1 milliard 300 millions
d'individus.
En 2050, c'est-à-dire dans
un peu plus de 25 ans seulement,
elle en comptera le double.
Comment on fait ?
Certes,
sur le territoire africain,
beaucoup de zones sont
sous-peuplées. Mais le problème,
c'est la concentration
dans les villes,
l'exode rural
qui entraîne la création
de métropoles qui sont des nids
à misère, souvent, non ?
-Je vais vous décevoir,
mais je ne veux pas vous mentir,
je ne pense pas
qu'il y a de solution,
ni dans le cadre africain
ni ailleurs.
Je pense que ce sont des réalités
avec lesquelles le monde
devra se débrouiller.
Mais il n'y a pas de solution.
Je n'en vois pas, en tout cas.
-La chute de Kadhafi
a quand même déstabilisé
toute l'Afrique de l'Ouest.
Vous êtes d'accord pour dire
que cette déstabilisation
a aujourd'hui
des conséquences importantes ?
-En Occident, on pense souvent
qu'on a fait une erreur
en renversant Kadhafi.
Je ne le pense pas.
-Vous ne le pensez pas.
-Pour moi, la faute
n'est pas de l'avoir renversé,
la faute, c'est d'être intervenu
ponctuellement
et de s'être aussitôt
désintéressé de la situation.
Je dirais que
c'est vrai partout.
C'est vrai en Irak,
en Afghanistan,
c'est partout le cas.
Quand on s'engage
quelque part,
il faut suivre l'engagement,
il faut continuer,
il faut rebâtir
quelque chose à la place.
Si on intervient ponctuellement,
qu'on perturbe une situation,
puis qu'on se retire en disant :
"Ca y est, le travail est fait",
c'est très grave.
-Il faut tenir la promesse
d'un monde meilleur.
-On aurait dû
et on aurait pu, à mon avis,
en Lybie,
avoir une autre attitude.
Le pays n'était pas
encore aussi anarchique
qu'il l'est aujourd'hui.
On aurait pu intervenir,
utiliser l'argent que ce pays
avait pour le développer.
Malheureusement, la communauté
internationale est incapable
de gérer des situations pareilles,
il n'y a pas un pays
qui soit capable de le gérer.
On a vu les échecs
des Etats-Unis, de l'Europe,
de tout le monde.
Et on se retrouve
dans des situations
comme celle
de la Lybie actuelle.
Mais est-ce qu'il fallait,
à un moment donné,
intervenir
et éviter un massacre ?
Je pense que...
...en me remettant
dans l'état d'esprit
qu'il y avait à l'époque,
oui, il fallait intervenir.
Mais il fallait intervenir
en engageant tous les pays,
en ayant une politique
sur le long terme
et pas d'une manière ponctuelle.
-Tout à l'heure,
vous avez parlé de l'Afrique du Sud.
C'est assez intéressant,
parce que nous autres
francophones,
on parle moins
de l'Afrique du Sud
que les anglophones.
L'Afrique du Sud vous fascine.
Vous avez une grande admiration
pour Nelson Mandela.
-Je considère qu'il est un modèle
et malheureusement,
ce modèle n'a pas été suivi
dans beaucoup d'autres pays.
Une des choses qui me fascinent,
c'est qu'il s'est battu
avec beaucoup de courage,
beaucoup d'abnégation
et de souffrance.
Et le jour où il a gagné,
il a dit : "Maintenant,
"on passe à autre chose.
"La bataille est finie,
on va construire
"et on va construire
même avec ceux
"qu'on vient de combattre."
Il est allé prendre le thé
chez la veuve de l'homme
qui l'avait jeté en prison
en lui disant :
"Ne partez pas,
"ce pays est à nous tous,
nous devons le construire".
Cet exemple de générosité
me paraît extraordinaire.
Et ce n'est pas
simplement la générosité.
C'est une générosité
intelligente.
Parce que c'est comme cela
qu'on préserve l'avenir.
Non pas en chassant
ceux qu'on vient de combattre
et après, en souffrant
peut-être des générations
parce qu'ils sont partis.
Il faut essayer d'utiliser
toutes les compétences,
même celles
des gens qu'on a battus.
-Avant même
la fin de l'apartheid,
vous avez reçu Oliver Tambo
alors que vous étiez au Liban.
C'était l'un
des fondateurs de l'ANC.
-J'étais passionné
par ce combat
et c'était mon premier enthousiasme,
ma première indignation.
Il se fait qu'Oliver Tambo
qui était le président de l'ANC
parce que Mandela était en prison,
il le remplaçait,
en quelque sorte,
à l'extérieur.
C'est lui qui voyageait
à travers le monde
pour parler de leur combat.
Il est passé par Beyrouth
et effectivement...
-Vous l'avez reçu.
-J'étais très heureux
de l'inviter et de parler avec lui.
Enfin, de l'écouter, surtout.
Parce que c'était
une figure merveilleuse,
lui aussi,
moins connu que Mandela,
mais un homme
qui a passé sa vie
à se battre
pour la même cause.
-Amin Maalouf,
vous me faites penser
à une autre figure très importante
de l'Afrique qui s'appelle
Léopold Sédar Senghor.
Il y a beaucoup de similitudes
entre vous deux.
D'abord parce que vous êtes
académiciens, romanciers,
tous les deux.
Lui était poète.
Vous avez dû écrire des poèmes,
d'ailleurs, mais vous êtes
surtout connu
pour vos romans et vos essais.
Vous êtes francophones et
vous êtes des ardents défenseurs
de la francophonie.
Et puis vous êtes
des passeurs, je dirais,
entre les continents,
les civilisations, les cultures.
Des passeurs
de culture, en fait.
Vous acceptez
que je dise ça de vous ?
-C'est tout à fait vrai.
-Vous travaillez à ça.
-J'aimais beaucoup Senghor.
-Vous l'avez connu ?
-Je l'ai un peu connu.
-Il est mort en 2001.
Vous êtes tous les deux là.
-Je suis même
allé le rencontrer
quand il était
encore président à Dakar.
-C'était en 1980.
-C'était un homme merveilleux.
C'était un homme
d'ouverture,
c'était,
ce que je ne suis pas,
un homme politique très habile.
Et donc, c'était à la fois
un homme de culture
et un des pères
de l'Afrique moderne.
Il répétait une phrase
que j'aimais beaucoup :
"Je suis un homme honnête,
ce qui n'exclut pas l'habileté."
Yves Thréard rit.
Je trouve ça remarquable.
On attend des gens honnêtes
qu'ils soient naïfs,
mais lui ne l'était pas.
Il était habile
et c'est ça qui lui a permis
de faire avancer son pays.
Et d'ailleurs,
jusqu'à aujourd'hui...
Je ne lui attribue pas tout le...
...tous les bienfaits de tout
ce qui s'est passé au Sénégal,
mais c'est vrai que
le Sénégal a connu une voie
un peu différente des autres.
-Plus stable.
-Une qualité de démocratie
un peu meilleure que d'autres.
Une dimension culturelle
beaucoup mieux que d'autres pays
d'Afrique et d'ailleurs.
Je trouve que son influence
a été bénéfique, certainement.
-Il a cette autre phrase,
quand on vous écoute
et que vous parlez
de votre passion
pour l'Afrique :
"La fierté d'être différent
"n'empêche pas
le bonheur d'être ensemble."
Vous partagez cette phrase ?
-Oui.
Et je pense que sa vision
de l'appartenance,
l'idée de dire :
"Je suis Africain
"et en même temps,
je suis Français",
"Je me sens extrêmement
proche de la France,
"je n'ai pas besoin de choisir
entre le Sénégal et la France",
c'est une vision
que je partage entièrement.
-Dans
"Le naufrage des civilisations",
vous dites :
"Je suis et Libanais et Français".
-Je pense qu'on a le droit
et même le devoir
d'assumer
toutes ses appartenances
et de réunir ces appartenances,
d'être une passerelle entre
les différentes appartenances
dont on a hérité.
-Je voudrais maintenant
vous faire écouter quelque chose
qui va éveiller votre ouïe
et que vous connaissez
nécessairement.
Musique jazz
...
Ca vous dit quelque chose ?
-Ce sont
des sonorités d'Ibrahim.
-Ibrahim Maalouf.
-Mon neveu, oui.
-Votre neveu
qui est un grand jazzman.
...
Pendant qu'on écoute
Ibrahim Maalouf,
votre neveu,
dites-moi quel est
votre auteur de littérature
africaine préféré.
-J'ai envie de vous parler
d'un homme qui est peu connu,
mais qui a joué un rôle
important dans ma vie.
C'était en...
...1974.
Je me trouvais à Nairobi.
-La capitale du Kenya.
-Oui. A l'époque,
on n'avait pas les moyens
d'information qu'on a aujourd'hui.
C'était quasiment
il y a 50 ans.
Je voulais consulter la presse
et j'étais allé au British Council
où il y avait toute la presse
internationale pour voir
ce qu'il se passait dans le monde.
Et je rencontre
quelqu'un qui travaille là.
...
Je parle avec lui.
Il avait à peu près mon âge,
on sympathise beaucoup.
Et on va prendre une bière.
-On boit beaucoup de bière,
au Kenya.
-Voilà, dans un endroit
qui s'appelait
"The fruit of the loom".
Je me souviens
encore de l'endroit.
Et je lui dis :
"Qu'est-ce que tu as fait
comme formation ?"
Il me dit : "Je travaille là
parce que c'est alimentaire,
"mais moi,
je suis romancier".
Et il m'a montré un livre qui venait
de recevoir le principal
prix littéraire du pays,
le prix Kenyatta.
C'est la première personne
que j'ai rencontrée
et qui m'a dit :
"Je suis romancier".
Je me suis dit : "Tiens,
on peut avoir comme métier
"d'être romancier".
Il s'appelle David Mwangi
et il signe Meja Mwangi.
Il a fait une longue
carrière littéraire,
il a été traduit
dans beaucoup de langues.
On s'est envoyé
quelques messages depuis,
on ne s'est jamais rencontrés,
mais si par hasard
il regardait cette émission,
je le salue
très chaleureusement
et amicalement.
-Merci,
Amin Maalouf. Merci beaucoup.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...